good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast it
is the toast X juicy scoop today I am
joined in Studio by one of my favorite
people on the planet someone who
actually is funny someone who actually
makes me belly laugh it's Heather
McDonald hello Heather McDonald hello
I'm so happy to be here you have not
been on the toast in forever I feel like
you were on a million years ago and then
we did virtual during Co which was dark
well the first time I was on I did not
realize that you guys were like a big
deal it was
we weren't yes you were it was back when
you had your Yahoo show the breath yeah
and I like got lost which is why I was
here so early you were very timely
because there was another time I was
doing it and I screwed up on Zoom so
I've screwed up with you twice so I got
here literally 20 minutes early I left
my house so early from Willen Hills
thank you cuz I was like I cannot and
then I got I decided to get in a fall
Delight outfit so we could take a nice
photo after you look like a delight
thank you I'm so happy you're here you
are one of my favorite podcasters one of
my favorite comedians and you are just
so funny and I cannot wait to get your
take on so many of like the moronic
things going on in the world absolutely
but before we start I just wanted to
catch up with you and before the show we
were having this conversation about golf
because your husband's a golfer right
yes and for how long have you been
married 23 years okay so I've been told
that like when I'm at that stage I will
appreciate the golf like I will want my
husband out of the house right now I'm
like annoyed because I have no one to
hang out with and it feels rude but are
you at the point now where you love it
well you know I was saying so of course
I follow you on the Tik Tok and Anybody
Everybody should and I feel like you and
I are a lot that we like are kind of we
watch way too much Tik Tok and like
can't stop and um so you were saying oh
you know the golf why does it go from 7
to n and I just was like I don't mean to
crush you but like that was in my
special from 2014 by the way 100% it's a
time it's a Timeless issue it's a
Timeless issue and it it either my joke
was something like it can either go from
3 to 13 hours yes because they can play
fast sometimes if they want but there's
no way for you to really know and then
there's lunch and then there's drinks
and then if they're into it they often
times can get away with doing another
Nine without paying for it oh is that
why yes or whatever they can go longer
right and so so when my kids were little
yes it annoyed me that my husband was
now my kids play my boys play with him
course oh that's actually really nice
and I like to go and then I'll go with
my sons and I will have like a cocktail
and I will like film them and it's just
like it's like my sons are like rock
stars to me yeah so any second I can
have as they get older and then my son
will play two balls he'll play Drake one
ball and Drake two and then I'm the
second ball got it so then I just go to
the Ping well that was my question all
some of the girls who are like you know
golf wives they're like listen I know
it's horrible but I recently started
playing because other than that I
wouldn't see them all weekend and it's
actually kind of fun so have you ever
like gotten into it as a sport I'm just
starting to do it with girls and let me
tell you it is really fun so you do best
ball which means you're not really
competing then okay so you're kind of
encouraging all the other girls because
whatever further ball whatever the
furthest ball is then you go and so it
goes real quick you only do nine holes
you drink you have lunch and you're not
you really don't care cuz you're like oh
my God I'm glad your ball went further
than mine and so it's very friendly I
can get into the lunch I think that the
lunch sounds amazing like I love a
country club lunch club sandwich fries
Diet Coke Vibe iced tea Arnold Palmer
yeah very like Palm Springs I know
you're a Palm Springs Queen yes I'm yes
I'm going to today you're every time I'm
with you you're like I'm going to Lina
after this my sister lives there I'm
like you I I have a I'm close to my
sister and she's been there for 25 years
and I never realized every time I
visited her until now that she has led a
superior lifestyle to M wow living in LA
but I never thought I could live there
because I was you know trying to be a
successful star and now of course it
doesn't matter where you live so now you
are a star yeah but I still have my
house here so it's all good that sounds
fabulous I just I love like following
you and your life I feel like you have
such a really like a goals type of life
you know I need to hear from people like
you and Heidi because I I got sucked
into um reading the hate oh God and God
the haters hate my happy life they hate
my happy life and I I find that the
happier I am especially like these days
I'm so happy in like my fitness and
health Journey people hate me so much
more like so if anything it
should make you feel good that it's
always it's like it's opposite the
happier you are the more hate you get
they run parallel so it's good and you
like me love to sing love to sing and um
they definitely don't like us singing
They Don't Like Us dancing I like to
dance I like and I do dance like an old
lady sometimes in too short of a skirt
and I like it I like it too it gives
Ramona energy I love it and there's a
lot that could be learned from Ramona
God enjoy your life I didn't know that
you love to sing can you maybe do a
little something for us um would you
like my karaoke song or my childhood
song childhood okay The Sun Will Come
Out
Tomorrow bet your bottom dollar that
tomorrow there'll be son Heather when
I'm stuck with a day that's Gray
wait I'm shook voice is so good
meanwhile The Toasters are like we did
not think we were going to get the
singing again oh my God wait I'm shocked
your voice is like
amazing I think it's okay I also think I
often times are off key but like I
sometimes my sister just goes you're
just loud you love to sing I bu it love
I do yes I do like to sing when you like
again my kids don't enjoy it of course
nobody enjoys it but me and you and but
I was thinking about driving over here
about how you like and I was thinking
about how you I was listening to your
the show yesterday with your sisters and
they were like you know and if if you
know if she if Taylor wants to go to
Kelsey's you know games to support him
and I was like oh and you know he can
always go to her concerts but as a
female standup or as a standup at all
it's like your significant other can't
go to every show like you can a rock
show like you could go to every single
whatever Red Hot Chili Pepper show
forever hear the same songs over and
over but like for us I remember one time
when Chelsea was breaking up with her
boyfriend at the time and she goes yeah
but like I can't imagine dating someone
and then what they're just going to come
to my show and hear the same jokes over
no it's so true that's no reason to stay
with somebody but you also don't have to
have them come every time well my last
tour because Ben's like full-time job is
working on Spritz our wine and that was
one of um the tour sponsor so Ben for
work came with me to every single show
and he actually didn't get annoyed or
like felt like it was repetitive he
thought he could do better he's like you
know next time you go out there he's
giving me notes I'm like excuse me I'm
like you shut your mouth right now he's
like you know you really need to work on
this 10 minutes I'm like what the
is going on right now yeah so have an
adverse effect yes I definitely don't
want my husband Peter um I barely want
him to come to the shows really also he
is white hair now and so he's pretty
distinctive looking so there was a few
times he came and the juicy scoopers
attacked we're like and and I mean I I
don't I don't know I don't want him to
get a big head
it's already big physically and I was
like I don't need you to now feel like
you're the star too well as two female
stars who are married we definitely have
this kind of responsibility almost to
protect our significant others and I
don't know if it's the same for you like
whenever Ben is a part of like Tik toks
or he comes on the podcast like he'll be
on tomorrow the girls love him so so
much and it's like I'm over here doing
the most doing backflips for laughs and
Ben's just sitting there like making one
moronic joke and they're like oh my God
Ben is the best we need Ben more I'm
like I'm literally working so hard that
is so funny yeah I think that um no we
so yes I don't want any notes and I
remember that early on I thought I I did
all this new stuff and he happened to be
there and I was so excited to hear how
great he must have thought it was and it
wasn't and then after that I was like
you know what I kind of don't think I
want you there anymore anymore unless
you're like actually doing something cuz
we're like filming it right other than
that like and I kind of feel the same
way with my friends and my friends have
been so wonderful my high school college
friends especially in their early years
of when like coming to the shows blah
blah blah blah and then I went to one
dinner and this girl goes and I go oh
I've had such a great show I did all
this new material and she goes oh good
because if I have to hear those stories
about Peter again and it literally made
me like switch to the point where I was
like I never want my friends to come
again yeah it's also just more Awkward I
would rather perform for a room of
10,000 strangers me too than 20 people I
know I get in my head about everything
yeah of course and I was like that even
when I was starting even if it wasn't my
material I would do a show with all
these women and this one girl had a
really funny herpes bit about the
commercial for herpes and I had a couple
friends that had the herps you know and
I specifically wouldn't invite them to
those shows if that girl was performing
because I couldn't like I wor I worry
about people's feelings and so one day
I'm about to go on stage and I go oh
like I forgot that this girl is
doing her herpes bit and my two her
friends or in the audience and I look
out and they're laughing harder than
anyone and that's when I realized I have
I can't be such a control freak what is
it when you're um when you're carrying
codependent I can't be a codependent
about my audience anymore or my friends
or whatever but when you have people you
really know and you know their history
or like all of a sudden you start to do
a joke about like whatever if I was a
widow or blah blah blah and then I
realized oh my God my friend really is a
widow like I just it's so those are the
types of people who actually need to
hear those jokes for most of the time
like those are the people who love it
the most and like the herpes thing so
yeah that's interesting but the husband
element and just like people I know
please seriously stay the away
don't come support I don't need you it's
horrifying especially because and for
you too I'm sure you talk so much about
your marriage and just like personal
things and for strangers to know about
my marriage it's okay for my in-laws no
I'm like please don't come please my
mother-in-law she loves the jokes about
her son she does she loves it more than
anyone the last show I did she did come
to it cuz it was in San Diego and she
brought like her ladies from her right
place and I don't care she she's the
best mother-in-law in the world I have a
great mother-in-law too she would pick
me over her son I think any day oh you
know what I have an amazing
mother-in-law I got to ask her who she
would pick me or Ben I do think she
would pick Ben which can be
understandable but I'm a delight mhm you
know you are a delight we are going to
do pop culture of course cuz that is
your beat I want to know before we dive
in like what are stories right now now
like ongoing developing stories that
you're obsessed with I mean the main
ones you know um I I've got I'm on my
drive down I am going to download the
audio of Jada's book because I need to
hear like I need I'm hearing all the
clips and I'm seeing all the the stories
and she's sounding like a real
and I'm like maybe if I listen to it in
her voice I'll either a not feel like
she's or she'll be more of an
but most likely I'll be able to imitate
it so I just would like to hear the
Cadence of her voice talking about Pac
yeah chis too Pac she calls him Pac yeah
I just saw a clip of her on J shett and
she was like well you know um Pac didn't
like anybody I dated but when I dated
will I didn't hear anything from Pac Pac
was Pac was okay with me dating will I'm
like what is this because I saw this
other girl do like a timeline and
everyone's like I think she's
bullshitting about him asking her to
marry him during Rikers because he was
engaged to somebody else and like I
don't know I'm kind of obsessed and I've
been obsessed with them with her being
an arrogant for years I do I do
agree that it's hard to know when
somebody's getting so much press and
they're coming off of as annoying if
they themselves are an annoying person
or if it's like all the clickbait and
the media making them annoying I think
that happens a lot then you find this
person annoying and then years later
you're like wait why did I feel like
they were annoying they're a nice person
and it's hard to know if like she's
getting just so much press to the point
where we all are annoyed with her or is
she being annoying and also like I think
because it's you know because the world
is in such incredible pain and turmoil
there isn't that much pop culture and
she it kind of was a perfect storm in a
positive way to to get this press for
herself that's very true people are just
like dying isn't a lot to talk about
mindlessness yeah and I feel like even
like the the New York posts and stuff
are like okay we got to put in something
dumb right now yeah like I mean some of
the dumb articles I've seen are like wow
you're really the bar is love for jalm
yeah like what the story is like 10
years old and you're just bringing it up
or you know you know we do a segment on
the toast called Kelly's mindless news
yes because a few years ago I realized
there has never been a piece of
Journalism published about Kelly Ripa
that was anything substantial it's
always just like I saw one today I love
that and I'm obsessed with Kelly and so
I wanted to know like what your thoughts
on that S I saw one today that was like
they shared especially now that they're
hosting their show together there's so
much more Mindless news and they shared
like this crazy story about how they
were you know eating peppers and got in
their vagina like it's just always so
dumb it's the I mean the fact that the
fact that they constantly talk about
their sex life it's a lot I just this is
what I think happened okay um okay I
think Ryan I think it was a mutual
goodbye for Ryan I actually don't think
he quit I've actually heard some stuff
that it was a mutual goodbye I could see
that he's very busy busy and over it and
maybe it wasn't he wasn't completely um
in you know behaving properly whatever
got it so um I think at that point
they're like why are we making our life
difficult why give her another host that
she is going to push out yes in three
years yeah let's you know she can work
do this for another 15 she could be
reges they could she could be 85 during
the show if we get the husband fine so
they get the husband and they're really
he's you know so then all of a sudden
they're just going talk more about your
life they love it talk more about the
sex life I mean I don't know if they
have I wouldn't be surprised if they
haven't in 10 years honestly I
love that when you talk about it so much
it's like why are we talking about this
so much what are you trying to hide and
oh you know what bothered me the other
day yeah is she um was there and the
daughter was there Lola and she goes oh
and then he said something about his dad
and then she's like oh Lola's here oh
she said she if she would sit in the
audience that I promis not to bring her
up I put the camera on her oh well I
lied and the girl's sitting there and
I'm like
I'm going like on this huge campaign in
the last couple months about people
using their kids for Content not
respecting their privacy whether it's on
a Tik Tok or whether you're 20 and you
went to your mom's show and you just
were like I don't want to be on camera I
landed on that side of Tik Tok too about
like family channels and how really
overexposing and and a lack of privacy
the kids have even even like infants yes
you know you're a couple hours
postpartum and you're filming your baby
I I I've been into I've been reading
about that too and I'm just like I'm so
grossed out by it I'm like why would you
do that like God she's you've already
used her for so much content saying that
she walked in on you doing doggy style
that you know like we God yeah no I
agree that's like a thing I think it's a
very small movement that a lot of people
are starting to get behind because
especially when like the with
influencers and content creators when
their whole brand is about the kids it
becomes like a really toxic lifestyle
where you know you're relying on the
kids to pay the bills and it's really um
it's it's not right and here's the thing
as as someone who has kids that are
older now my youngest is uh
17 they listen like when I was talking
about my kids in my standup I said none
you guys can never see my stand up until
you're 16 and they're like why and I go
cuz you won't care when you're 16 you
won't care that I talk about your Hot
Wheels being parked next to a
because it fell in the toilet when
you're were taking a dump you won't care
when you're 16 you'll find that funny
but when it's happening right then you
know what I mean like these kids won't
care when they're 30 that they're Mom
and Dad talked on a talk show about
all the time right but right now
at 20 sorry no you're fine right now at
20 it's like it's awful yeah no I AG
it's embarrassing so that's when I was
looking for stories this morning that
came across I'm like I need to know what
Heather thinks about they're so annoying
and I will I still need to know and I
think you've talked about this
too and listen it's annoying because
some people question about why I'm not
friends with people anymore as if
everyone's friends with from people they
met in first grade but I do want to know
what happened with Jerry Seinfeld's wife
and Kelly Rippa is there drama there
they used to be really close and now
they're not oh my God I that's like a
side of the world I I didn't follow
where do you sleuth on the internet like
when you're being like looking for
gossip would you go to Tik Tok where do
you go I love the Tik Tok you do like I
woke up Ear woke up at like 2:36 today
for I went back to bed but I did a solid
hour yeah on the the talk honestly I
don't know who I would be without the
talk but I think I would be a better
person I'm like Heather stop stop turn
it off turn it off add and then even
when you hear that thing you've been
scrolling way too long I'm like shut up
you know you have a problem when you get
that thing multiple times a day like hey
you've been scrolling for a while maybe
take a walk but I do find really good
interesting stuff especially for the
podcast it's our job to like know
everything and make stuff up so we need
to be on Tik Tok exactly so we're going
to dive into the fast five stories and
Heather I just have one final question
for you are you ready to deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
absolutely today's episode of the toast
is brought to you by State Farm the
state far F personal price plan helps
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and it
comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and most
importantly an affordable price just for
you because after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences think about it like this
what are your music playlists podcast
feeds and social media Scrolls all have
in common well spoiler alert they're a
reflection of you we all know my social
media is full of these days like the
girlies on OIC um lots of True Crime
recently but it's so personal know it's
the algorithm it knows me so well so me
and Jackie we're such different girls
right we have such different needs on
social media and we have such different
insurance needs and that's what's so
fabulous about the State Farm personal
price plan that's what it has in common
it gives you options to help you
personalize your coverage so that you
can protect what you care about most and
all at an affordable price just for you
so you can see more of yourself
reflected in everything you love so
Jackie and I you know we're two girls we
host a podcast together we have all the
same thoughts all the same life
experiences but even our insurance
insurance needs are so different and
State Farm gets that cuz you know Jackie
is a homeowner she she's a Tesla you
know that that changes things I don't
have a Tesla so like a good neighbor
stay Farm is there let me say that one
more time like a good neighbor St Farm
is
there I'm coming for Jake's neck call or
go to statefarm.com today to create your
State Farm personal price plan prices
vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary again call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time all in one place all
on your terms it's 2023 you need a
website whether you run an e-commerce
site whether it's for your job whether
you have a side hustle or you're a
photographer a videographer you can
showcase your gorgeous work you need a
website and it can be a really
intimidating thing to do because a lot
of people spend like a lot of money with
fancy companies to have a gorgeous
website made but thanks to Squarespace
you don't have to do that so whatever
you're looking for on Squarespace there
is a product feature for you so whether
you want to create an online store sell
custom merch uh showcase a video
collection an asset library and the best
part is that if you're using Squarespace
for e-commerce like to sell anything
they also have a point point of sale so
you can sell in person by connecting to
a square reader to the Squarespace app
and you'll keep your orders your
inventory your customer data all in sync
with your online store so there's no
reason not to have a stunning website
because Squarespace is easy it's
accessible and you can do it all on your
own so head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain and I know what
you're saying turty why should we trust
you oh I don't know I was a blogger I
built many websites in my days and I've
used a lot of different Services a lot
of different companies I can tell you
Squarespace is the real deal their
flexible website templates are stunning
they will look professional and it will
be just you in your computer and there's
nothing better than that so again head
to squarespace.com for that free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain all right our first story I'm I'm
obsessed with this whole Saga but I also
do want to get your take on Travis Kel
and Taylor Swift but the latest update
is that he bought a $6 million mansion
in Kansas city that has more privacy as
his romance with Taylor Swift has been
heating up so the tight end uh and
Taylor have been enjoying frequent rende
Deus in the recent weeks on Tuesday he
signed on the dotted line to close the
deal making him the new own owner of a
plush pad that boasts a waterfall
swimming pool mini golf Etc for only 6
million I want tosas City I want to kill
myself living here in La what's so funny
is that up until this point his house it
was a million-dollar home which I
imagine in Kansas city is still very
lovely but it definitely lacked any sort
of privacy for Taylor can't just like
roll up to the curb in a Suburban
neighborhood and walk in so I'm sure
this one has a gate and everything he's
leveling up his lifestyle and honestly I
respect we okay do we really think now
the sisters who are my sisters too your
sisters yes were saying that um they
think that it's been going on longer
than we know about and I I don't know
but he could have certainly been looking
for a bigger more established home for a
year for knows yeah CU he's making a lot
of money he's won the Super Bowl twice
he can live in a home that cost more
than a million dollars I don't
necessarily agree that it's been going
on longer than than we know especially
because he's in such an interesting
inflection point in his life where he is
in the news every single day and he's
forced to kind of speak on it because he
has a weekly podcast and I can't think
of someone in recent memory who's ever
been like so a part of the cultural
Zeitgeist and then forced to speak on it
all the time you know on on his show
that's about his life as a podcaster
yourself was there any moment in that
you were a little jealous of the fact
that they of course is that even a
question but I'm also like a deeply
jealous person I know that they already
had like a good show going cuz they're
brothers and they had the cute mom and
the super all that stuff but I was like
I mean The Perfect Storm are you kidding
me I me you and I are out here on the
daily sweating our doing the most
spreading our legs and this man just
comes in and has the number one podcast
it's only a year old no I'm jealous and
I'm upset I complet I I think that's
okay to say yeah yeah exactly so I don't
think it's been going on longer because
he really couldn't have gotten away with
it and we've every time like there's an
update in their relationship we know
about it so my thing and I said it a few
weeks ago is I do think this is it you
do I do elaborate I think that she's so
pragmatic in her life she is such a good
girl she has done everything right and I
think this final tour sure she could go
back and do another tour but I could
also think she could be like I'm ready
to put it down for a while yeah and I'm
30 what is she like 32 yeah 33 and I
think she that's an appropriate time to
start like having kids without having a
lot of issues or being too old or being
too young and I think she's ready to do
it and I think she really likes him and
I think she wants the normaly of you
know his best friend is his brother the
mom isn't it's a and it's not an actor
or a singer so I think it's going to
happen I mean I think at first for me it
was so a rebound fling like very not
serious but the more I see really she
seems so happy and I agree I do think
she she's not a girl who wants to you
know run around with a million guys
she's very much she was in a six-year
relationship she's super family oriented
and I agree I think that's kind of uh
the be like in the beginning what they
really had in common I mean her mom
literally looks like his mom they're
twis and like you know yeah when she
would speak about her mom and everything
and I don't think her mom was having
daquaries with her in the eth grade like
Britney's so I think she and her mom
have a solid solid relationship I agree
and I think so much of Taylor be like
staying a really nice normal person has
to do with the fact that like throughout
the entirety of her career her mom has
been at her side for every major moment
highs lows and I think she's a really um
good example of like you know good
family values you know and I I could see
it I could see this being it I I I know
it sounds crazy but I I don't disagree
and I'm also going to go out on a limb
which is going to be shocking for 2023 I
think she will get married before she
gets pregnant oh you think she'll be a
very traditional yes I could see that I
think they'll get married
married as a surprise we won't even know
it'll be one of those like you thought
you were going to a birthday party yep
but it was you know 100 People Wedding
yeah and that is going to happen before
May of this year wow I me May of yeah
May of 2024 okay I guess we'll have to
watch this episode in May of 2024 and
see if Heather McDonald was right I
really do I really do need someone to
mark my um you need to keep pred Ledger
yeah yeah what have you successfully
predicted
oh my God there's been a bunch I can't
think of one but my latest one I did say
before Joan who got had to leave the
golden Bachelor before that happened I
said on my show there's a blonde with a
very good facelift who's about 60 and I
think she's going to be the golden
Bachelorette and they're going to be
younger guys like between 50 and like 65
right to court her and then she left the
next episode she left to be with her
daughter and so maybe she'll make a
grand return and then I will have that
in the bank that that was one prediction
but a lot of my predictions have come
true and some for some have not no of
course that's part of this job like
making stuff up throwing at the
wall and some of it sticks and you're
like look at me I'm a genius and then
you don't talk about like the other
thousand things that there's so many
that have not there's so many like
relationships and stuff that I've called
that are not true so overall like do you
like this coupling of totally me too
totally it's just also fun to see like
really hot rich young people being young
hot and Rich and not weird and not weird
and not making their girlfriend wear
nylons up to their nipples and giving
on boats in VI and walking
around or wearing weird outfits for
attention or just you know it's so true
there's so much um normaly in this
relationship I love it I'm back to bring
bring the normies bring back normaly I
completely agree yeah um okay our next
story is like major if you're into True
Crime for me it's major because I think
a lot of girls my age this story like
changed our childhoods right you know
when a lot of us were like 15 16 17 and
you know people were going on spring
break and then Natalie Holloway happened
everyone's parents like this shook the
world so how old were you when this
happened that's a good question like in
high school I was in I was in fifth
grade so Olivia was in like was entering
high school so this was just a story
that's stuck with my generation and our
parents so remind everybody what
happened so Natalie Holloway went
missing and was you know did they ever
find her body she was just presumed dead
no they never found the body when she
went on spring break in Aruba in 2005
and it was just this major True Crime it
was this insane mystery people had their
theories and now what is it 20 years
later it's been a long time coming but
Beth Holloway finally knows what
happened to her daughter Natalie in
Aruba back in 2005 Jordan vandersloot
the now 36-year-old man believed to be
responsible for Natalie Holloway's death
pled guilty Wednesday in a Birmingham
Federal courtroom to wire fraud and
extortion charges as a part of the plea
deal Vander slot agreed to tell Beth
Holloway how her daughter died and where
her body was stacked Natalie went
missing on a high school graduation trip
to the Dutch Caribbean Island Vander SLO
was the last person to be seen with
Natalie though he was a suspect from the
beginning Aruba authorities never
managed to build a case in the US
however Federal prosecutors in Alabama
had charged him with extortion and wire
fraud in 2010 while he was already in
prison in Peru for killing a college
student Stephanie Flores in his hotel
room in Lima in the indictment the US
government said that Vander had
attempted to get $250,000 from Beth
Holloway in exchange for information in
detail details in Natalie's death today
the United States held Jordan van
vandersloot accountable for his scheme
to exploit a mother looking for
information about her missing daughter
the US attorney said in a statement for
Beth Holloway it wasn't the guilty plea
she would have liked to see she said I
can tell you with certainty that after
18 years Natalie's case is solved as far
as I'm concerned it's over it's over Jen
Jordan vandos salute is no longer the
suspect in my daughter's murder he is
the
killer um and now a judge sentenced him
to 20 years in US federal prison and but
he has to return to Peru to finish his
sentencing over there if he serves more
than 20 years there he will not need to
return to the US to finish his sentence
for extortion and wire fraud so in the
extor doesn't seem enough it doesn't
seem enough he should be till the day he
dies so he's being he has now been
charged for extortion and wire fraud not
for murder but in the uh evidence for
the murder I mean for the extortion he
is on record there's an audiotaping say
that he saying that he did it okay so I
mean what was so awful about this cuz I
remember
is that it was you know they went on the
college trip there were lots of parents
that went and she was out with friends
got a drink met some guy in a Lobby Lo
saw her I mean the amount of like 2020s
and stuff that was on this and here they
had this person that was so susp so so
suspicious everything and then he goes
and kills some other girl right and so
does time for that but what I think is
so amazing is that I feel like what I
really want to is the documentary on
this now because um you know what my son
said the other day he was like about the
um serial killer in Long Island he goes
oh I'm kind of bum we know who it is I
wish they would have held it till after
the Netflix doc I go life doesn't work
like the Netflix do but that's how they
know they're like I won't enjoy this
Netflix stock now that's also like the
weirdness of True Crime especially True
Crime podcast like people whose job it
is to like and I said for a while the
fact that like morbid that huge podcast
was in comedy yeah it's true crime is
weird because it's become a form of
entertainment while really I think a lot
of the times forgetting like this is a
was a 16-year-old girl her whole life in
front of her a beautiful girl like it's
a unmistakable tragedy and it becomes
like commercialized it's crazy but I
what I think is so interesting is I want
to see if the
mother solicited this fraud to get him
because I'm like this was the thing had
he not done this then she wouldn't know
that and then I I read that he
bludgeoned her but I do well I guess we
still don't know where the body is so
whatever information she got she maybe
she knows finding the body in a tangible
way is probably not going to happen was
probably thrown out to sea or something
and so obviously it's not buried
somewhere that she can go yeah it's a
terrible story and I just can't believe
like in my lifetime like CU I remember
this I was so young but it took the
whole country by storm everyone was
talking about it that now we're still
talking about in 20 years later I feel
like we never get resolution on these
cases like you know John Benet these
cases that take the World by storm we
never get like full concrete evidence or
resolution and it's really just so crazy
that that we do and think about if
you're the mom one of the moms that was
The Chaperone oh not that it's your
fault these kids are 18 they can drink
at 18 at that Island that's why they
chose it but it like makes me say I
would never want to volunteer for that
really yeah I would never you never did
that for your sons no I never wanted to
be that like I I don't the only thing
scarier than losing your own child is
losing someone else El oh my God totally
I mean I'd honestly rather be on watch
when my child gets kidnapped then on
watch for someone else's because it's
just course the responsibility yeah so
this is just like a crazy turn of events
I can't believe um like we finally got
the resolution of something that just
felt like forever we were never going to
know remember when she started dating
John B's dad who did the
mother the mother dated John B's dad dad
that's crazy because his wife passed
right and they dated briefly yeah I
don't think it was serious but it was it
was a dating situation I mean I imagine
these are two people who have a lot in
common but that's really crazy yeah it's
like awful but like yeah that's
weird it is weird but then you know
people meet up you know but no no no and
you can't help you know who you love
yeah our next story is so funny
Alex Earl the Tik tocker is getting
dragged for saying she looks like a mom
on pickup Duty when she's in reality
wearing mini shorts and heels so moms on
social media are poking fun an
influencer Alex Earl after she joked
about wearing heels to pick up her
future kids so she shared a clip of
herself getting dressed for a football
game throwing on a pair of very small
mini shorts and white pumps and a very
tight um bodysuit and she said I feel
like a mom picking up her kids from
school she declared while rocking an
orange bodysuit an aqua cap and Tiny
Jimmy chew purse she said I don't know
why a mom would be dressed like this to
go pick her kids up from school but
that's what I'm going to be dressed like
and of course like actual moms flocked
to stitch the Tik Tok being like no this
is actually what we wear and they're
literally like looking like Haggard in
ripped sweatpants dirty t-shirts and
their hair is in a bun they look nothing
like Alex Earl who is tanned to
Perfection wearing the tightest clothes
on planet Earth and
heels okay so is this girl like like an
insane Genius Like was this planned out
no what is this that's the thing about
Al I don't think this is particularly
interesting or funny but the fact that
all these people are talking about it
then she scored right yes so I I don't
think it's planned I think that's really
kind of the magic of Alex Earl and why I
think she's like one in a million and
and there's so many Tik tokers and
nobody nobody cares about them as much
as they care about Alex enjoying her
show um I it's very new I feel like it's
hard to tell you know the success of a
podcast that's what's so interesting
about podcast I'm sure you know me and
Jackie talk about this all the time you
know a YouTuber you know your numbers
are public your subscriptions are public
with Tik to I mean with podcast it's
really hard to know if someone's podcast
is killing it and that's we we have
recently started keeping a list of all
the celebrities and influencers who
started podcasts and never finished them
you know do you know that's one of my
favorite things is to hear that it's I
sometimes I just go and look and I'll be
like what happened to that per and then
I'll see oh last episode was May of 2022
y well I guess you you guess you ran out
of stories guess you ran out of friends
so only time will tell you know
everyone's podcast is popular when it
launches right a great example of that
and when we started making this list I
tottally forgot remember when Ashley
Graham had a podcast Kim was on it yeah
what happened with that hasn't released
an episode in over a year yeah she ran
out of friends and she got tired of it
right it's hard work and whoever
convinced her to do it oh you can sit on
your bed and talk to your dog on a
Tuesday night and you're going to make a
million dollars a month right who the
hell wouldn't do that right but it's
like yeah and with everybody also having
a podcast you can't really rely on my
celebrity guest it's unfiltered
it's like we've all heard it like you
got to be able to be different yes so
time will only tell like the true
success of a podcast is in its longevity
yes and I think what spurred us to start
that list was amada's podcast was
cancelled I I did hear that she is going
to continue doing it
elsewhere but I'm not sure but the thing
is I think a lot of people also start a
weekly podcast and were like this is
going to be easy money I could talk for
an hour a week it's a tremendous amount
of work it was even weekly and the
amount listen for like a year and a half
during Co or two years whatever mhm
these agents had nothing to do MH so
what they could do was convince their
people and they could work deals and
blah blah blah so was on slot of it and
people were just throwing millions of
dollars at people because they were like
oh you have three million followers on
Instagram yeah but seeing you in a
bikini doesn't mean we're going to also
listen to you every two days a week for
an hour on our commute so with the Alex
Earl podcast I do want to say I think
there is potential there and I think she
leads a very interesting life that a lot
of people can relate to but then a lot
of people can't but they find it
fascinating and and almost uh aspiring
you know like well listen when it starts
to dip she's got to have the stepmother
on oh for the tell all about how her
stepmother was a call girl or a sex
worker whatever you want to call it
today for this Governor or something
yeah for Elliot Spitzer yeah I so I was
in high school at the time and Elliot
Spitzer's apartment was right by my high
school and it was we would leave school
and you the streets were closed it was I
remember that time very specifically I'm
curious did you hear Alex talk about it
on call her daddy oh she did talk about
it she did she did I think she was very
should have blown her load on that she
should have saved it for her own podcast
she was very nervous it's probably like
she got to have the mom on though had
the Stepmom on for the for her own and
she has said in interviews that like in
her you know recent surge in public life
her step mom has actually been really
helpful like she has enormous experience
dealing with this type of stuff but it
was really interesting to hear her talk
about about it I think she was
incredibly nervous she was um cuz this
is really not her story to tell she
wasn't you know with the governor it's
like it was other people in her life
also I've heard that you know there
might have been maybe the maybe the step
mom maybe her dad wasn't and the mom
weren't totally broken up no she said on
the podcast when the Stepmom came in she
cheated the dad cheated okay she said
that very um clearly on the podcast it
was I thought it was crazy that she was
talking about it yeah good for her yeah
yeah and I guess time will tell about
the podcast and then she's dating a
football player too right yes so I think
people look at that and it's like oh my
God like it's just so fun to see someone
so young and skinny and perfect looking
just having this like the ride of their
lives you know do you feel like she's
like the Kardashian of our time like how
everyone was obsessed with Kim and like
they like Kim was Kim was refreshing yes
because she was curvy and had brown hair
okay we hadn't seen someone with brown
hair and Curves in years like oh my God
like she still was like a size two but
everyone was like freaking out and that
she was had inter interracial
relationships so that was like a big
thing and now I I'm like I kind of feel
like well this girl showed that she has
a messy apartment and everyone like
like jacked off to it yeah I
don't know if I necessarily think of her
as the Kim Kardashian because I think
especially when she did her episode on
call her daddy and and you see on Tik
Tok she's tagging her sister and they're
trying to bring other people into the
fold but I don't know if it's having the
same sort of effect that the Kardashians
did like once you met Kim and then you
met all the sisters like it was like you
couldn't get enough of them collectively
and I I think it's I don't think that
the same thing's happening with the
family what about the the other
ticktockers the demonos or whatever
demilios demilios and who's the other
girl Addison yes what's going on with
those people Addison has taken like a
major leave of absence from public life
her family her parents were like out
here embarrassing themselves and making
Tik toks and cheating and it was like
really bad oh right oh I interviewed I
interviewed the girl that was dating the
dad yes and I actually didn't release it
oh because I felt that she her story
would not be well received and it
wouldn't be good for her interesting
yeah well Addison took a lot of time off
after that because it was like
embarrassing and I think it was a lot
and I think she made a lot of money and
she got really famous and she just
needed some time she's slowly making her
way back to public life she is acting
she did that Netflix movie and now she's
in that um Eli Roth uh horror movie
Thanksgiving that's what she should do
yeah like why you've got your money why
don't you actually pursue something
besides dancing right you know like the
dancing's not going to last and the
dancing was a 2020 Trend it's true and
the demilio girlies they have that
reality show they're very commercial you
know they did Dancing with the Stars
they have a line at Target they have a
line at abber cromie they have lines
everywhere lines here lines there what
happened with their reality show I
watched that for a minute I watched the
first season it was beyond depressing I
think it was actually really indicative
of the Mental Health crisis in this
country like I think these are two young
beautiful Fabulous Girls with every
opportunity and they are miserable yeah
and so it was actually a very it wasn't
a super interesting show but I think it
was very interesting because that's what
goes on in the minds of young people now
and it was dark right and now the second
season just came out and I I wasn't I'm
not watching it no I'm okay yeah okay
good well good for Alex today's episode
is also brought to you by Quint we love
high-end luxury goods as much as an Exon
but our wallet is not on the same page
that was until we found Quint Quint is
our go-to for luxury Essentials at
prices Within reach so Quin creates
Timeless Classics that never go out of
style you'll have them in your closet
forever their capsule wardrobe mus haves
like 100% Mongolian Kashmir sweaters
from $50 to washable silk tops and
dresses and flattering pants make
putting together any outfit that much
easier the best part is that all Quint
items are profit priced 50 to 80% less
than similar Brands so by partnering
directly with top factories Quin cuts
the cost of the middleman and passes the
savings on to us and Quin only works
with factories that use safe e and
responsible manufacturing practices and
premium fabrics and finishes we love
we're also you know in our wardrobe
building era I'm all about capsule
wardrobe I learned about it on Tik Tok
and that means investing in a a few
solid good pieces that you can wear a
million different ways and have forever
so I have this gorgeous Brown catmere
sweater from Quin that everybody uh is
always commenting on I wear it on the
toes like once a week and gorgeous black
slacks like just one good pair is all
you need so get affordable luxury with
quins go to quinn.com toast for free
shipping on your order and 365 day
return returns that's qu
nc.com toast to get free shipping and
365-day returns Quin Qi
nc.com toast and start looking fabulous
it's time like we are looking fabulous
these days okay today's episode is
brought to you by the farmer's dog Theo
is the most important person in my life
and I say that knowing my husband is
sitting right next to me nobody tops
Theo and his health and well-being are
the most important
things are none like it's not even a
question and when it comes to his food
we are a farmers dog family we switched
to fresh healthy dog food a little while
ago and there have been so many benefits
so the farmer's dog makes and delivers
fresh healthy dog food it's developed by
vets it's nutritionally balanced and
it's made from real healthy ingredients
to hum human food safety standards it is
the best options for dog at all life
stages because it's not kibble it's not
canand goo it's just real healthy food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are highly processed and they can use
much lower quality ingredients than they
claim to and they are extremely
difficult to portion accurately so if
your dog is yo-yoing you know getting
heavy and then thin it's hard to know
exactly how much to feed them and that's
what the farmers's dog is so fabulous
they're taking all of the worry and
they're delivering it straight to your
door which is fabulous now there's so
many benefits once you switch for Theo
number one issue was his breath like it
was gross and it wasn't just dog breath
gross it was like really something is
wrong here gross and it's been so much
better his uh coat is so shiny he has so
much energy and farmer dog is great for
any dogs whether you have a young dog a
senior dog it's never a bad time to
start investing in your dog's health
because they keep you happy the least we
can do is keep them healthy that's not a
farmers dog slogan but it sounds like
one get 50% off your first box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdog.com toast
plus you'll get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com toast
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box and free shipping our
next good for Alex I agree it's it's
nice to see like uh keep doing you keep
doing you our next story Chris Jenner
may bring Megan Markle and Prince Harry
into the Kardashian fold Reports say
Megan and Prince Harry could be making a
potential came and Chris Jenner's hit
family reality show the Kardashians
according to report insiders close to
the Duke and Duchess and the Jenner say
that the Mamer is vying to get the
exiled Royals to appear in their hit
Hulu show as their apparent friendship
continues to evolve it's no coincidence
that the Kardashians all move in the
same circles as me Megan's New Circle
and Insider told B Bella magazine it's
just a slam dunk for the two families to
team up but Chris doesn't want to push
too aggressively too soon even if it's
just a cameo that's a huge win for Chris
the business side is now in motion and
looking very lucrative rumored talks
between the sussexes and the Kardashians
are reportedly still in the early stages
Jenner is committed to betting the
sussexes into her family's Inner Circle
I have thought it was bizarre that that
since Megan and Harry's moved to
Hollywood there hasn't been any sort of
relationship with the
Kardashians well I mean this would
benefit the Kardashians a lot you know
because it we don't really see har and
and Megan like being themselves right
and after the bomb of the podcast and
everything else that's another podcast
that's on our list yes and I was like so
what is next are we going to see them
feed the chickens are we going to see
her being like a real housewife planning
a party for little bit or whatever or or
or not because once you step in that
reality you're not going to get any
more acting roles but maybe she doesn't
want to learn lines and be an actress
she has said she doesn't think she'll
return you I mean the beauty of being on
a reality show is that you can be with
your kids you can be home they come to
you you have a salad whatever you have a
solid and um so yeah if that's something
that she's thinking about it's a total
win win for both of them so that we
could see them being a little more
normal maybe and then people would be
like you know what I would like to see
this reality show with them and see what
happens yeah I I Would by the way like
they are total grifters and social
climbers though and they do you know
like they'll meet someone at a party and
then Harry will do the followup not her
and he'll be like oh my wife was talking
to you about your house in Aspen we were
thinking about going there next month
and then they'd say well my God stay
with stay at our place right and then
they go oh but how would we get there oh
um are any chance you're going to be
using your jbt that weekend no we're not
okay wow and then all of a sudden the
person even though they're really rich
is like and then they realize they're
actually not that fun to talk to right
and so then they go and now they have
stink on them so now the billionaires
don't even want want to take a photo
with them anymore but see that's why I
find it so shocking that they haven't
hung out with the Kardashians like that
up like Kardashians are upper a list and
Harry are on their own level I think I
always say like they're on their own
level I think that's only similar to
like the Obamas you know like kind of
royalty politician energy and you know
they went to Ellen's birthday Kim Chris
was there like I feel like there have
been many opportunities for them to have
become friends or even just be spotted
out at like having dinner well both
Chris and Megan I believe are very good
about meeting someone doing the followup
and becoming the friends right she is
excellent that like the first time I was
invited to Chris's Christmas party I
couldn't believe I was invited like I
just met this girl once at a at a lunch
right and then I said to my this other
girl that was invited I go who the hell
has a Christmas Eve party no everybody's
with their family on Christmas Eve your
Christmas your Christmas parties are
like on the 16th right you know like
something like that and she goes oh no
Heather you have to go and this is when
it was much smaller she's like you have
to go I'm like what am I GNA do with my
kids she goes She's Got Elves to watch
them and I was like how old were your
kids at the time oh little like baby and
then like a four and a seven-year-old
wow and I was like okay like this like
this is amazing so you know now she's
best friends with Lauren Sanchez who's
engaged to Jeff Bezos that's the way to
go and like it is and I remember when um
when Caitlyn who was Bruce at the time
started flying helicopters with Mark
Anthony in Hidden Hills okay and that is
when it was like everything we planned
for is working now we're going to be
friends with JLo right so it all works
out and it makes friends that it makes
sense that these people would be friends
right they have the Yachts they have the
billionaire friends billionaires want to
hang out with billionaires but I I mean
I think besides just wanting the content
for Hulu I don't think Harry and Megan
are they're no Lauren and Jeff B I would
put my effort more in that relationship
than that Megan marle I agree by the way
like I would be friends with Lauren and
Jeff they seem like a good time like I
the more I the more they share Yeah the
more I'm like okay their their
announcement like how we all found out
they were dating was such a bizarre time
remember with the national Inquirer but
now that I've had time to digest like I
think they're a really cute couple I
really do I've met Lauren many times
years ago and even before she got with
Jeff I started to write her because she
was like she's like she like a full
helicopter pilot wow she like knows how
to fly helicopters oh and I was like hey
remember me come on juicy scoop then
she's like dating Jeff gets
engaged and then I was probably didn't
speak that highly of the cheating that
happened there because how can I it was
so juicy yeah um I don't think she's
coming on juicy scoop anytime soon but I
wouldn't wait by the by the phone for
her to call you back I don't think it's
happening but I love to see Chris jedar
at the birthday parties and all that St
me too I like that friendship but I want
to say they were running around the same
they could have been friends 20 years
ago and nobody tried of course she
didn't try to be friends with Chris and
Chris didn't try to be friends with her
but now it's a match made it happen
that's always how it happens and I just
find it interesting that Megan and Harry
have not infiltrated that group yet oh I
think they've tried you think I think
they've tried and now maybe it'll happen
right you know um I mean it could it
could make sense but I don't know that M
I think Megan still thinks she's above
the Kardashians wow really yes I think
she at this time because they have
little kids they could have had a play
date she could be hanging out with true
and everything the kids is a great way
to get Jessica Simpson and Kim yeah but
I don't know that I think they all think
of themselves as like I don't need them
they need me you know what I actually
could see that being the case yeah like
both Kim and Megan like not wanting to
be the one to to reach out yeah yeah
that's interesting and they don't need
to have playdates they all have each
other play with all the kids play with
each other our fifth and final story is
about my favorite person on the planet
it's wenth palro do you love gwenth
palro do you hate I feel like you um I
think she I really loved her movies yeah
I loved her movies and I guess she was
in something recently that was like a
streaming show because politician yes
and people said I would like it so I
have to watch that um I mean yeah I
think she's out of touch and everything
I mean that's why we love her yeah um
but I mean look what she's made good for
her no and like with all the ridicule
like everything she still she came out
on top with goop valued over a billion
now does she podcast she does goo has a
podcast but is she like on it all the
time or no that's a good question I
don't think she's on it all the time
it's there people and you know that's a
good way if you can't commit to doing it
every week like make it a company
podcast yes so she is uh swearing she
will disappear from public life after
her retirement she says no one will ever
see me you'll never see my face again
camera running literally but wait what
is this retirement happening so
obviously she hasn't acted that much her
last major film was 2019 but now she's
looking to sail off into the sunset
without looking back so she's on the
cover of bustle's digital magazine which
I found really interesting cuz that's
like a fake magazine and gu p is an AA
star she looked unbelievable like she
had tushy out and everything but I was
like damn you that ass I
think it's a sick ass or okay I don't
okay I don't remember her ass being that
juicy so I think everyone needs to study
that pose I think there's some like when
I have chicken legs okay but when I kick
up my leg I have this incredible muscle
in my thigh that wouldn't be there
unless I kicked up my leg so I saw that
and I'm like I think if I twist my legs
like that and turn around maybe it pops
your ass a little bit I think we could
all learn a lot from this fake digital
magazine cover I thought it was so weird
like she could be on the cover of Vogue
and she's on the cover of
bustle okay regardless why is jessle on
the cover of Rolling ston oh let's talk
about that I'm so glad you brought that
up I don't think she was on the cover
they did a spread it was but it was a
very fancy photo shoot cuz it's kind of
like the it was more like the fall and
Rise of Jessel because she was
insufferable my God in the beginning she
was just like really trying so hard on
real hostes of New York and she we
weirdly like rose From the Ashes and
emerged as like some sort of hero on the
show and people are taking note well I
think she Rose from because she was
treated so horribly by sigh who's just
like the worst person on Earth the wor
she's just like she's like
what just answer the question just
answer the question actually you know
what don't answer because I don't care
it's actually funny how little I care
about you I'm just go away like she's
just the worst and then and I think also
people like look I thought the Vietnam
thing was weird too and then I was like
God I
mean just like why are you trying to
tear down someone's marriage when when
there's evidence now or people coming
out that he that her guy was married
when she started working at the bar and
got with all that kind of stuff so it's
just like but I just feel like God
that's all these shows are I there's a
an element where I am just like grossed
out I know it's like just at the end of
the day like what are we doing we're
tearing down women and their marries
we're like here it's literally sell your
soul to the devil the devil being Bravo
you most likely your kids will hate you
at least for part of their lives and
you're definitely your marriage is going
to crumble there's a chance that some
freak is going to go in the papers and
realize you did something wrong on your
taxes and now you are going to lose
everything possibly go to jail yeah but
guess what you get to go to Bravo
con but you're famous you get to go to
Bravo con and yeah no that's a really
good point um so back to yeah so she
said I will literally disappear from
public life no one will ever see me
again so later in the interview when she
was asked if she would attempt to teach
others how to age gracefully she says
I'll probably try knowing myself or I
might be like this I might just
disappear and no one will ever see me
again I feel like she's talking a lot
about she's really good friends with
Cameron Diaz and that's what Cameron
Diaz did she made $100 million in Trek
and was never to be seen again she
completely retired she came out of
retirement to do that amazing movie The
Other Woman and then she went back into
retirement she has a lot of money she
had a baby she has a wine company so she
still like posts on Instagram and
but she does not act and we never see
her you know what I think is so
interesting about how Pamela Anderson
you know went out with no makeup and
she's like a few years older than I am
definitely not ready to do that may
never be may never be yeah but she's
also prettier much prettier obviously
naturally anyway and she goes you know I
remember my mom saying you're just not
going to want to wear makeup after a
certain point and I'm just like oh I
don't want to you know she went out I
don't want to compete with clothes and I
do feel like when you're so stunning
like a Cameron
Diaz you know and you're this youthful
thing and something about Mary and all
that and you're just like I don't want
to put myself out there anymore I don't
want to be scrutinized she had a child I
believe kind of late in her 40s and it
doesn't mean that it doesn't mean that
all these people won't come back right
they really should they should come back
when they're going to be the grandmother
mother of the bride R whatever like
don't give it all up be that Jane Fonda
right but I even think Jane Fonda had
years where she took time off yeah and
where she was just like I just don't
want this right now and I don't know how
many face lips I and she thought
obviously a lot of work Jane Fondo but
like I just think it's kind of a hard
thing and like even as I get older I'm
like and I see my friends after a couple
years and I'm like oh everyone is
looking a little older oh this facelift
is not that good and I'm not going to
that guy and like whatever but I'm kind
of seeing it and it's just a TR it's
just a truth and like you
know so I think that can be part of it
where she's just like I don't really and
the effort that it takes to do a movie
is so much work if you don't need the
money and you're not craving the Oscar
anymore the Oscar it's also like the the
attention I think that's why it's so
hard for a lot of women to take or not
women just people in Hollywood to take
that time off because you know for the
amount of time that you're out of the
public sphere like that technically is
your star you know going down and for a
lot of people when you've been on that
roller coaster for so many years like
the thought of you not working and not
being seen and not being spoken about is
like the worst thing that can happen to
you or it's like when ree Witherspoon
said you know the rolls dried up you
know um I wasn't getting them anymore so
what did she do she bought every book
that she could and bought the rights to
it and made her own thing but that is
part of it it's being an actress a Model
A Sports person it is a short window you
shouldn't expect it to last forever
that's why when the friendch people
asked for let's all get a million in
episode because they're like we'll
probably never have another sitcom so
you got to make it why you can make it
and and also in have enough going on in
your life and healthy wise that if
you're not going to the Oscars anymore
you're not going to miss it and I don't
think any of them miss it no me neither
I think Cameron Diaz is probably the
happiest she's ever been yeah she had a
baby and like yeah what do I need it for
she's got that wine which I did think
was kind of interesting the avaline wine
did you see her okay what I also think
and I know you're going to like it's
like listen we've all accepted that
these big Hooch Stars had to get into
our space yeah podcasting yeah
podcasting and instagramming and all
that stuff and then they're they're
doing the things where they're doing
makeup and all and it's like that was
for us but okay yeah like can we have
one thing and so then she's
doing oh I'm oh I'm I'm putting my
Avalon thing at the store and she's
doing this dumb thing acting like so you
know like this wasn't like a
7500 what, billion shoe like this was an
expensive shoe there were 25 people
involved this wasn't just you and your
assistant going to Walmart like if you
were going to do something for your
liquor Brown I would literally walk into
the store in my pajamas yes and do that
and so I was like well let's do that
let's make it look like Claud is with a
million dollar budget yes yeah so again
don't begrudge but I wish more people
would see how annoying it is same with
you know same with like uh Jennifer
Aniston being like doing doing this is
my this is my brand yeah
yeah you know like there's no product in
her
hair yeah I mean it's an interesting
time where I think during Co so many
celebrities started doing other things
to make money besides you know their
traditional trades which was acting
singing Whatever and they made a lot of
money social media podcasting and so
they're still doing that now in addition
with their you know traditional skills
and it's annoying because that's our job
yes stay away let us have one just one
little thing but I do feel like when you
do like I do feel like you and I and our
on our podcast we were really we're good
about it and the people appreciate it
and it's like never going to go away no
so that's what I was saying at the top
of the show as long as we've been doing
it you know so Jackie and I always say
cuz people are always like well what do
you want to do you know like and for a
while I think when we were younger it
was like oh I want to have like my own
TV show and now we say like we love what
we do if we could be doing this forever
in the nursing home like podcasting then
that's a dream right and I think we look
at someone like you who has grown kids
and is still at the top of her game and
still does this like that's what we want
to do so it's amazing to see it's like a
a future that you would Envision for
yourself yeah I mean I and I really do
love it cuz someone was like you know we
were driving and Peter was like oh
should we get a lotto ticket which I've
never been into buying a lotto ticket
ever but I'm like whatever if you want
to go get one fine and I'm like even if
I won a billion dollars I would still do
juicy scoop because I may once a week
maybe once a week but I love waking up
and not always you know sometimes it's
not always the greatest comments but I
do like I need that um reflection
whether it's like doing standup or
hearing the comments the next day I
don't think I would be happy not being
creative and I do like the immediate
response of today's world feedback yeah
the feedback so I do like all that so I
don't yeah I don't know that I would do
either I always thought I was going to
be a mom and a sitcom and I had some
opportunities that then never were to
fruition Pilots stff it wasn't meant for
you and that's always what I envisioned
I would be getting the Emmy and doing
all that that's so funny and so yeah I
still I was thinking you're probably out
here like Fielding talk show offers now
no no one wants me on their talk show
which is disgusting to be a guest or to
be have your own by the way I used to
say like my dream job was to have a talk
show and until I realized a few years
later that being a talk show host
requires very little talking and a lot
of listening to other people like your
guests who wants to do that that
sounds miserable right that's why we
never have guessed on the show well
listen even when I try so hard there'll
be some YouTuber that's like let your
guest talk I'm like I just listen listen
I interrupt but this one I really let
them talk but I almost think there's
people that are listening that if I
don't interrupt they're like almost
bummed no I've literally been sitting
here being like I know the juicy
scoopers are going to like rip my ass a
new one if I interrupt Heather so I've
been like trying to be so good but I
know that I still probably interrupted
you well I love the toast I love you
thank you so much for doing this if you
guys enjoyed the podcast check out juicy
scoop with Heather McDonald how many
episodes a week now three uh two and
then Friday patreon or subscription so
and that's always at least 30 minutes
Heather's so consistent her episodes are
up always at the same time never like us
she's on top of her you should
follow her and check out her patreon
thank you for doing this love you guys
tomorrow's episode is with me and Ben
and we've actually got a big
announcement we're getting divorced no
I'm Kidd no but we do have a great
announcement so we'll be tuning in
tomorrow love you guys thank you so much
for listening to the toast londay
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please fre
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found
Spotify public radio I cast box all the
place beautiful setting wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you tomorrow
bye